[موسيقى]
مظلات المسجد النبوي التي يستظل تحت ظلها
230 الف مصلل تقيهم من اشعه الشمس وهطول
الامطار وتتشكل ابعاد المظله الواحده منها
نحو 25 مترا مربع ووزنها نحو 40 طن داخل
مسجد النبوي توجد 12 مظله منقسمه الى
حصوتين في ساحات المسجد النبوي 250 مظله
المظلات هذه بارتفاعات متفاوته وحده تعلن
اخرى الارتفاع المنخفض منها 14 متر و40 سم
والاخرى ب 15 متر و30 سم
جميعها اثناء الاغلاق يكون ارتفاعه 21 متر
و70 سم
[موسيقى]
مئه الف متر مربع هي المساحه الاجماليه
التي تغطيها مظلات ساحات المسجد النبوي
التي تعمل بنظام الي لفتحها وغلقها يتم
التحكم فيها عن طريق غرف تحكم رئيسيه في
بدروم المسجد النبوي او مواقف المسجد
النبوي يتم فتحها قبل الشروق الشمس ب15
دقيقه ويتم اغلاقها قبل غروب الشمس ب 45
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
يعد الشكل الهندسي للمظلات فريد الشكل
والتصميم ويشكل التاج والرمح في نهايه
المظله من الاعلى المصنوعان من النحاس
الملمع والمطلب الذهبي بريقا خلابا يلفت
امطار المصلين
والزوار من المسجد النبوي سلطان السلمي
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات